hi everyone I'm super bummed I can't be
there in person but I'm really excited
to be able to talk to you all today my
name is fonty and I am a
biologist this here is my
office and for the past 10 years of my
career I've been trying to understand
some of the complexities of our natural
world more recently I came across an
opportunity to work with other
biologists to transform their ideas into
our packages and suddenly I found myself
in this really unfamiliar landscape
there were all these new Concepts I
didn't understand and I didn't know
where to
start up until this point of my career I
considered myself as an AR code consumer
I used code developed by other package
maintainers to get to the answers for my
research
questions and the expectation now felt
like I had to become an arode
producer and the difference between
these two roles felt really intimidating
and I think this is a really common
experience when you're trying to First
Look pick up a new skill so in spite of
all these mixed feelings I followed my
instincts and you used my skills as a
biologist to navigate through this r
package landscape and today I want to
share with you all my field guide to
writing your first r
package so this field guide isn't a
step-by-step walkthrough if you want you
can check out my workshop that I wrote
for our ladies and it's not this field
guard isn't really about the technical
stuff either as you heard in Jenny
headley's talk earlier on before the our
packages book is really an incredible
resource for
that instead this field guide is an
encouragement to start your first our
package a very gentle stroll through one
and some of my tips on how to deal with
the things that you're likely to
encounter along the
way my hope is to support and and help
those that feel really overwhelmed about
about this process which was me at the
beginning and to also remind those
seasoned package maintainers of what The
Beginner's mindset is like and to
encourage them to use some of the ideas
I share today as a way to support those
who are learning the
ropes so you might be thinking why go
through all this effort uh in building
an our package but I hope from the
content from all the other previous
speakers that um that is that the reason
might be more apparent but I like to
also think about it like this the code
that wrote for a particular project
that's Now hidden away in your
directories may actually be a solution
to another data scientist's problem and
maybe with some tweaks it could be a
solution to 10 more data scientists
problem what I'm trying to say is that
the impact of your code cannot be truly
realized until it's in a sharable format
and that's where the r package comes
in so for us to go on this journey
together we're going to need a few
things and these uh packages have
already been mentioned in these previous
talks so use this and Dev tools are
essential to the package building tool
belt and um as Matt has alluded it's
great to store your package on GitHub so
you can unlock things like using the G
uh GitHub issues and all the goodness
that GitHub has
offer so where would we
begin whenever I enter a new landscape
for a walk I like to get my hands on a
map so here is a really rough sketch of
a map of an our package at its core your
app package contains your ideas your
functions or data that you want to share
with the community next to those things
are your documentation these are your
help files and vignettes to give your
users some guidance on how to interact
with your r
package there's also something to
describe to describe your r package so
this description file will give the user
some higher level information about who
wrote the r package what it does
generally and what dependencies it may
have and where to go if I have any
questions
there's something called a namespace
this control what comes into your r
package so what uh functions you're
borrowing from other packages and what
gets made and what goes out of your r
package what gets made available to your
user when they load your r package into
memory most packages will contain tests
these like I think are the most elusive
part of an r package these ensure that
your r package is behaving as it should
and to let you know what it
isn't what I really like about having a
map of an r package is that it breaks up
what seems like a really complex idea
into these smaller manageable pieces and
so as you're learning you can focus on
one thing at a time and so also using
this map you can see the
interconnections between all these sub
components and as Hadley had mentioned
before it's you don't have to put these
components together using the function
create package and use test that these
functions will lay down the foundation
of the package and this is where you're
likely to begin
so as you're building your ey package
questions will likely come up and this
is totally not natural and normal and
when they do I invite you to be curious
and one way you can do that is by using
what I call the science poke so the
science poke originated from me going on
nature walks and coming across something
new and peculiar and me grabbing a stick
and investigating it from a safe
distance so in your AR package science
pokes have really simple ways to help
you get unstuck that are really low
effort and low stakes so for example I
was showing my friend Mark how to write
his first ey package and he goes how do
you add package documentation and I'm
like well what do you mean he said oh
it's that piece of writing that pops up
when you call the help file for deepar
for example and I said off the top of my
head I don't know but there are
functions in use this to add a read me
add vignettes and add articles maybe
there's something in there for package
documentation
and so Mark and I poked around the name
space we use this and found a relevant
looking function for his
purposes the next thing we did was to
call the help file for Ed package docs
to figure out what it does and how to
use it and if it's really suited for his
purposes and that was all it took to get
MK
unstuck another way I like to get
unstuck is actually to have a poke
around in the GitHub repository of an
existing r package there's something
super comforting to seeing an the
program is code doing exactly what you
want to achieve it's like holding the
answers to an exam that you never got to
prepare for and it just gives you that
much bit of confidence to take
inspiration for their code and to try
things out in your own r package which
leads me to my next point is that
experimenting with your code is a super
effective way in getting unsto and uh
the idea is that you change one thing at
a time in your code and call the
functions document which updates your
documentation or load all which loads a
preview of the recent changes uh and
using doing this you can see the
immediate effects of the changes you've
made onto the r package and it's through
this iterative cycle that you can figure
out how um mechanics of an r package
works so as your r package takes shape
uh you're going to come to a point where
you're going to release it to the
community and that can feel a bit scary
so I just want to say whether it's bug
that you've uncovered post relase or
someone's larged to GitHub R issue or a
feature request or a question all of
these unexpected encounters are really
part of the package building process and
when it comes to that time I invite you
to embrace all that uncertainty and all
its glory and to treat those steps as an
extension to building your ey package
and not your reflection of your ability
as a package Pro uh
developer as a matter of fact whenever I
go on field trips with my friends and
sometimes we're lucky enough to uh come
across another uh creature in the nature
uh 100% of the time all these unexpected
encounters are considered as positive
and enriching experiences they teach me
something about the diverse life forms
across all these different Landscapes
and I think the same can be said about
the code bugs that we uncover in our art
packages they teach us something about
the context that the bug has been
produced you learn how to detect them in
your tests and ultimately addressing the
bugs um becomes in this iterative cycle
that leads to the Improvement of your
package and uh and in some cases these
bugs can actually be sources of
inspiration for new Futures but I
understand that um our initial reaction
to bugs and anything uncertain is to
resist so if you want to feel more
prepared for these things I suggest you
to se out the bugs so whenever I'm on
fut trips with my friends we don't wait
for some cool animal to cross our path
we go looking for them so we'll be
flipping rocks or turning over logs and
you can do the same with your ey package
you can get your coding buddies to try
it out and give you some feedback or get
someone to read your documentation with
the fresh pair of
eyes so I hope by seeing how I've
approach writing our packages has
demystified some of that process and
dispelled some uh that hesitation to
start if there's one take home from this
talk I hope that it's whether you're a
seasoned package maintainer or just
starting out with your first off package
is that I hope we can all code more like
a biologist by that I mean be more
Curious and be more willing to
scientifically poke and prod at your
code to get it to work and to overall be
more embracing about all the things that
you're going to encounter along the way
because we as an our community are going
to need all the ideas we can get to
sustain this thriving growing art
ecosystem and with that I know this is a
short talk I want to thank you all for
listening and tuning in and I'm yeah
thank you for pait for inviting me and
happy to yeah hear feedback or questions
thank
you thank you fonty that was great um I
do have one quick question I was
wondering if you had any advice on like
marketing that first r package to either
your friends or people on internet after
you've built
it oh um I generally because if you're
building an r package it's generally for
a dedicated Community I think it's
initially before the pay me the mass
release I would maybe shoulder tap or
message a few folks that um that would
find that H package interesting as a
kind of soft release after that would I
suggest relying on uh social media like
Masen is a really great thing um for
reaching out to the ey
Community thanks are there any questions
from the
audience no okay thank you fonty we
really appreciate you coming in no
worries thank
[Applause]
you